What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity and welcome to another episode
of 'Challenge Pongfinity'!
This is the series where YOU challenge US
with your craziest ideas related to table
tennis.
We will go through all of your comments in
the comment-section and choose the best and
most creative ideas and use them in our next
video.
So make sure to leave your comments in the
comment-section below and we will give you
a shout out in the next video.
So Jake Reynolds wants us to play table tennis
over the curtains.
If you mean these curtains, that's going to
be difficult!
BUT
Let's do it!
Caleb Clarkson asks if we can split a table
tennis ball by hitting it at a sharp upright
knife.
Thanks for the idea Caleb - we will give it
a try!
Next up AlexArconiteGames wants us to play
a 1 minute rally of only using under the leg
shots or behind the back shots.
I'll go behind the back, you go between the
legs!
Sure!
Okay, the next suggestion is from GarlanVlo,
and he wants us to rip a piece of paper with
a ping pong ball.
Well it didn't quite rip but we made a hole!
There.
Now it's ripped.
Thanks for all your really good ideas, we
had great time filming today's session!
Make sure to subscribe to the channel by clicking
here and don't forget to leave your ideas
in the comment-section below!
Until next time!